[Musica]
Sì quando quando Alberto mi ha chiamato
e mi ha detto Vieni a Lerici a te e io
gli ho detto subito eh sì per tre motivi
Beh il primo confesso e Lerici voi vi
rendete conto di avere avuto un bel culo
di essere nati il più bel posto del
mondo
questi scenari questo panorami secondo
perché degli amici qua dei grandi amici
il vostro sindaco e
Marco boutique un grandissimo
sapere che state nel paese più bello del
mondo dovete anche sapere che avete uno
dei più grandi Secondo me autori di
storie di avventura che ci siano al
mondo Quindi ho fatto un pranzetto con
loro per venire però vi confesso che
quella parola lì Mi ha anche colpito
molto mi hanno colpito due parole
etmosfera Bravi bravi bravi bravi
perché è arrivato il momento di parlare
di sentimenti e di emozioni basta regole
qui ci stiamo tutti
combattendo con le regole invece un
grande problema di sentimenti e delle
emozioni che sono figli di sentimenti e
l'altra parola la parola di Ted che è
progetto e quindi ho immaginato intanto
immaginato Cos'è per me l'atmosfera e
Gabriel chiamarsi quando gli chiedo ma
come quando cominci un romanzo cosa
immagini parti la protagonista partirà
la trama E lui dice no mi viene in mente
un'immagine
centrali di solitudine era una sfera
appunto è cronaca di una morte
annunciata un triangolo poi dentro gli
scrivo le cose Io ho immaginato questa
roba qua è chiaro che ho immaginato la
sfera
e sono partito da questo
con l'idea di partire dalle emozioni dei
sentimenti per creare un progetto
quindi parliamo in positivo cosa
dobbiamo fare
la prima operazione quando si fa un
progetto è l'analisi analisi e
costruzione progettuale la parte a cui
dovete dedicare più tempo l'analisi
perché se sbagliate all'analisi andate
alla strada sbagliata
poi se sbagliate la costruzione
progettuale è tornata indietro rifate
togliete non è un problema ma quello che
non bisogna sbagliare è l'analisi
proviamo a fare in maniera emozionale
l'analisi in tre minuti
di Come siamo piazzati oggi
e stiamo camminando su un grande viale
quello lì è un grande viale ci devono
camminare 8 miliardi di persone da una
parte abbiamo un burrone
si chiama emergenza ambientale credo di
non dover aggiungere una parola a quella
che aveva detto Francesco un attimo fa
ha centrato esattamente il problema
dall'altra parte abbiamo Guardate
l'altra parte una roba strana che io
chiamerei sconcerto digitale
Voi ci siete nati tutti in mezzo a
questo fantastico mondo governato da due
numeri lo 0.1 che ci aiutano a vivere
molto meglio Tuttavia siamo sconcertati
per tre motivi primo non sappiamo bene
che fine faranno i dati la nuova moneta
del Terzo Millennio i dati i nostri dati
personali i dati del Company come
saranno usati visto che sono cinque
Company che governano tutto E in queste
Cloud in queste nuvole vanno a finire
tutti i nostri dati
che alla fine sono posseduti dopo che
aziende secondo non capiamo ancora bene
quale sarà il confine Fra l'intelligenza
naturale che è fatta di emozioni di
sentimenti con quella artificiale che
naturalmente deve essere fatta di
ragionamenti
è un grande tema che ci sconcerta ultimo
Grande elemento sconcerto e non capiamo
bene come sarà il lavoro del futuro
perché si cambia tutto Non è più
pensabile che il lavoro sarà passare 40
ore alla settimana insieme ad un gruppo
di lavoro per costruire delle robe nello
stesso posto
perché se la prima parte
dell'intelligenza artificiale diciamo
del mondo digitale ha sostituito tutti i
nostri movimenti più banali nelle
fabbriche e adesso sta incominciando a
sostituire anche quelli un pelino più
sofisticati e poi sempre più sofisticati
ma tutto bene purché lo governiamo
sconcerto digitale davanti a noi abbiamo
delle aiuole
con dei fiorellini che spuntano belli
carini ci piacciono il cui nome finisce
tutto per ismo
egoismo menefreghismo populismo
sovranismo sapete che un nome se gli
aggiungi unismo diventa brutto provino
buono aggiungeteismo diventa buonismo
brutto proviene i due termini che hanno
nella radice ismo capitalismo e
comunismo sono interpretati nel mondo
nella maniera più Bica possibile sia da
una parte che dall'altra da un lato
dittatura burocrazia e tirannide
dall'altra parte denaro denaro denaro
profitorienti che è una calamità simile
dietro abbiamo un grande evento che ci
spinge
impossibile da arginare sulle migrazioni
dei popoli
e contro i venti che va per male lo sa
che c'è da fare bisogna stare Le Vele
nella maniera giusta perché questo vento
diventi positivo e ci portino la giusta
direzione il grande immigrazione dei
popoli sopra cacchio dopo aver visto
tutta sta roba Siamo gli occhi al cielo
la guerra e l'emergenza
energetica questa situazione
Insomma mi rendo conto di non avervi
descritto la Primavera di Botticelli
Diciamo che più L'urlo di manch
quello che avete anche visto prima le
slide delle slide forse dei neuroni
c'erano molto bella Ebbene
Siamo davanti
a delle scelte Francesca prima aveva
spiegato bene le radici della parola
crisi Queste sono varie crisi crisi
deriva come diceva lei la Crisis Che
vuol dire scegliere daclino Che vuol
dire distinguere siamo anzi delle porte
dobbiamo scegliere
una certa strada Io ho appena scritto un
libro uscito due giorni fa che si
intitola è nata prima la gallina
tre puntini forse
che cosa voglio dire con questo tipo
sono 52 racconti che parlano
dell'ottimismo mettendo a confronto i
vari ottimismi della storia Giulio
Cesare con Vercingetorige Napoleone con
Wellington Socrate con Platone per
entrare
dobbiamo scegliere e non è un grande
problema è tutta la vita che noi umani
siamo in crisi non è un grosso problema
tutta la vita la crisi ci accompagna non
possiamo non vivere in una crisi Il
problema è scegliere non stare lì a
lamentarsi di tutto il tempo e trovare
le soluzioni
bene
Incominciamo dal tema più più più
attuale e posso su quello previsto un
minuto e mezzo posso farlo in 10 secondi
tutto quello che ha detto Francesca è
vero e abbiamo risolto siamo già al 40%
di energia da fonti rinnovabili
noi italiani cacchio parliamo un attimo
bene di noi Siamo primi in Europa per
l'uso delle plastiche monouso siamo
l'88%. siamo i primi al mondo per il
riuso del legno al mondo siamo quelli
che hanno maggior numero di aziende
biologiche biodinamiche ci siamo
dobbiamo soltanto accelerare ma
accelerare per accelerare bisogna
eliminare la burocrazia
la burocrazia la fa la politica gli è
stato vietato di parlare di politica sia
al terno si parla di politica quindi non
vi parlerò di quella politica lì che
spaventa la politica partitica Siamo
talmente rotti da la politica partitica
che addirittura non parliamo più della
cosa più importante al mondo che la
polis l'arte del governo di cui Invece
bisogna parlare Questo mi serve soltanto
per spiegarvi il mio concetto di logica
logica l'ha inventata Aristotele il mio
suocero una delle più grandi a livello e
ha fatto due grandi storie Aristotele
più figo di quattro eh Pericle Socrate
Platone Aristotele 173 anni che ha
cambiato la storia del pensiero umano in
Oriente in occidente
e a un certo punto ci spiega che cos'è
la logica Aristotele che è l'analitica
che vuol dire sostanzialmente con
linguaggio di oggi fare ragionamenti
assennati per arrivare a soluzioni
assegnate lui la spiegava per esempio
dicendo gli umani muoiono Socrate e
umano Socrate morirà giusto logica
la logica in politica ed è scritto anche
nella costituzione è si fa politica
virgola attraverso i partiti politici
virgola per il bene comune giusto
Sì noi diciamo invece si fa politica
virgola per il bene del partiti politici
è il logico e sta roba che il logiche
ormai è passata e del motivo per cui
l'ho fatto fuori e questo è un problema
perché da lì nasce la burocrazia che ci
crea dei problemi per cui
me ne frega che non si può parlare di
politica e non parlerò di politica
partitica ma intanto faccio una proposta
Noi dobbiamo riparare la nave
doveva convincere i politici non farà
più propaganda a fare la polis come lo
facciamo votando una volta sola ogni 5
anni
il loro problema è che ogni anno si vota
ogni anno si vota e quindi devono fare
perché le amministrative sono importanti
devono fare la propaganda Io capisco
perché il loro obiettivo si fa politica
per il bene del partito così magari per
4 anni fanno politica per il bene comune
e poi si occupano del loro partito
Guardate una piccola cambiamento e si
può fare senza problemi Una volta l'anno
andiamo là con tre schede votiamo
Scusate sono messo davanti ma se non
ripariamo la barca è inutile che
discutiamo o bischiamo sulla direzione
da prendere perché tutte le belle cose
che ha detto Francesca su cui sono
d'accordo al 100%. se poi la politica
non se ne occupa siamo fottuti perché
certe decisioni devo prendere loro
Io voglio iscrivermi alla scuola di
quella ragazza che è venuta qua prima
fantastica vestita di verde che fa la
maestra
perché lei assolutamente è centrato il
tema vi traduco come l'ho vissuto io il
suo discorso from Duty to Beauty bisogna
passare dal sensore al sesso del piacere
il grande errore della scuola del
Novecento è stata quella di impostarla
Sul dovere la fatica luoghi luoghi
angusti
dobbiamo veramente cambiare accentrato
il tema al 100%
. perché mi butto sulla scuola
perché dobbiamo cambiare i sentimenti e
mi ha insegnato un grande teacher tipo
lei verso livello bravissimo che noi
impariamo a ragionare con la testa col
cuore tra i 7 e i 17 18 anni lì e
andiamo a scuola e cosa deve servire la
scuola
cambiare i sentimenti Oggi è un problema
di sentimenti bisogna passare la
sfiducia alla fiducia dal coraggio dalla
paura al coraggio da pensare in piccolo
da pensare in grande dal criticare
all'aiutare Dai bene al tristi Sapete
bene al tristi
va bene altro Tu fai delle proposte ti
sbatti Ah ci va bene altro vuol dire lo
facciamo mai il tubo il gatto parli del
Terzo Millennio bene al tristi dai
benaltristi ad aiutare ai compromessi e
questi sentimenti si imparano a scuola
quindi primo proposta quattro materie
nuove
educazione civica la sostenibilità
studio dell'educazione agroalimentare
educazione e le vocazioni del nostro
paese educazione alla poesia all'arte e
alla cultura
c'è una risposta ahimè che vale per
tutte a tutti i problemi del nostro
paese qualsiasi problema che voi mi
chiedete potrei rispondervi in questa
maniera Siamo terzi in Europa per PIL
siamo 23° su 27 paesi Per tasso di
lettura un popolo che non legge non ce
l'ha può fare E perché non leggiamo l'ha
detto bene lei la maestrina perché ci
hanno insegnato che fatica leggere
un dovere e dobbiamo trasformarlo in
piacere fronduti to Beauty dobbiamo
leggere cosa serve leggere dei dubbi
quelli che non leggono sono pieni di
certezze le riconoscete subito quelli
che leggono sono pieni di dubbi e hanno
disponibilità a cambiare idea
prossimo protosta
pnnv protagonista della nuova nazione
verde alla fine delle scuole medie
superiori un anno decentemente pagato
dallo stato a lavorare in un'azienda
italiana che si occupa di emergenza
ambientale quindi centrali di
trasformazione di energia da fonti
rinnovabili eoliche oppure fotovoltaico
oppure idrauliche
termorializzatori a zero impatto aziende
agricole biologiche biodinamiche
forestale ripiantare alberi quella roba
lì un anno a lavorare lì per capire
indirizzare i ragazzi nella direzione
giusta e noi posti di lavoro li faremo
con quello e salveremo il mondo con
piacere
seconda proposta
Questa l'ho chiamata pptr vanno di moda
gli acronimi no
ptr vuol dire partenza presa di
coscienza tornanza restanza alla fine
dell'università un anno decentemente
pagato dallo Stato all'estero chi non va
all'estero non può capire un tubo
dell'Italia 0 bisogna andare all'estero
per capire che esistono altre religioni
altre culture altre bellezze
meravigliose il primo ragazzo che ha
parlato che ci ha raccontato del viaggio
lento mi è piaciuto da matti sapete che
mi ha fatto venire in mente Luca il più
figo dei quattro evangelisti che
racconta il viaggio lento di Gesù
Secondo me l'uomo più figo di tutti i
tempi è stato un viaggio lento e Luca lo
racconta da progressista E l'unico che
ci racconta la vostra Maritano Matteo
Marco e Giovanni non ne parlano mica
perché era una roba un po' strana un
fatto che uno che sta male viene aiutato
da un eretico
è l'unico che in esclusiva fa parlare
Gesù coi due ladroni
domani sarai con me in paradiso
fantastico mi ha fatto venire in mente
questo e quindi abbiamo bisogno di
partire un anno all'estero secondo prese
di coscienza dall'estero capisci
l'Italia
capisci che culo aiutano sia in Italia
il paese di coscienza Avete presente un
po' come quando attaccate un quadro ad
una parete poi vi allontanate un po' ma
per vedere se sta bene nella stanza
dall'estero capiremo quanto l'Italia sta
bene nella stanza del mondo
tornanza
restanza perché nel frattempo avremo i
soldi per pagare tutto questo avremmo
creato un sacco di posti di lavoro
Prima di tutto
voglia di crescere lasciamo le tasse
esattamente come sono precise non nel
caso tanto non ribalteranno perché con
il casino che abbiamo 30.000 miliardi di
debiti e bisogna adesso aiutare tutti
per l'energia eccetera però
sul supero sul più sull'incremento degli
utili perché sono il 10% chiaro il
concetto facciamo venire voglia di
crescere però solo aziende che lasciano
gli utili Rivestiti nella propria
Company però sono aziende che stanno
rispettando il piano di emergenza
mentale che è stato scritto tutto chiaro
premiamo le aziende virtuose e gli
facciamo pagare meno tasse sulla
crescita Cresceranno davanti e chi
crescerà
crescerà chi si occuperà del
delle nostre eccellenze
ai giovani dico sempre Non immaginate
nessun mestiere del mondo che non
riguardi
nel suo mestiere lo stesso che non
riguarda il mondo Noi siamo condannati a
vendere bellezza
vendere bellezza la terra
siamo condannati non è colpa nostra di
essere nati il più bel paese del mondo
che sfiga
pensate che è incredibile l'ultima
indagine di wingamalo
130 paesi 1.200 interviste quindi una
roba potente per ogni paese sull'indice
di fiducia e di ottimismo 2020 siamo
riusciti Arrivare ultimi
cioè Ma guardate il mio sforzarsi
nascere in Italia ed essere più
pessimisti del mondo più sfiduciati
prima sentimento che dobbiamo cambiare
noi dobbiamo occuparci del mondo
dobbiamo vendere la nostra scienza del
mondo oggi è assolutamente possibile a
raddoppiare l'esportazione delle nostre
eccellenze Noi esportiamo quest'anno
abbiamo sfondato il tetto di 500
miliardi Io sono orgoglioso di
appartenere alla classe dei imprenditori
che ha aiutato l'Italia a superare 500
miliardi di esportazione era una roba
irraggiungibile merito dell'impresa e
dei lavoratori
di questi 500 100 sono eccellenze
pazzesche nel campo del cibo della moda
forniture industria manufattoria di
precisione industria manufattoriale
della Bellezza bene facilissime da
raddoppiare perché perché c'è la domanda
il problema principale dell'impresa è
avere la domanda
Ok Christian è una domanda spontanea
pazzesca dobbiamo solo fare due o tre
gesti che non ho il tempo di raccontarvi
facciamo 50 milioni di turisti stranieri
ci guarda come ammalata mi sembra
normale che Roma faccia 7.8 milioni di
turisti stranieri e ehm
Dubai ne faccia il doppio quindi non è
normale
Noi abbiamo la possibilità di
rapportarli a 100 che un numerino facile
sono 100 miliardi più 100 miliardi
freschi che entrano che ci servono per
pagare tutti i servizi rivolti ai
giovani perché appunto molto sulle
scuole dalle elementari Perché i giovani
possono essere i più grandi Tizian per
noi grandi io posso imparare dei miei
nipotini posso imparare tutto dei miei
nipotini L'altro giorno mio nipote
Nicolino
a 9 anni metto Allora tu sei o punto
farinetti@ffronto raffredda.it perché
abbiamo un'azienda di vino si chiama
Fontanafredda che è stata fondata dal re
Vittorio Emanuele
Allora il re è Vittorio Emanuele
chiocciola fontanafredda.it
non con una visione grande su futuro
bene
bisogna mettere uno stipendio minimo
garantito non il reddito di cittadinanza
1500 euro netti appena si va a lavorare
e così verrà voglia un sacco di gente di
andare a lavorare
e poi bisogna rendersi conto
Guardate avete notato come siamo finito
bene e ho messo non ho messo non ho
fatto il paraculo mettervi Lerici capito
ho messo le Langhe
era facile per dire che che siamo andati
al più bel paese del mondo qui Guardate
cosa hanno fatto gli agricoltori in
15.000 anni lavorando sulla terra
Guardate che meraviglia che è arrivato
qui dove abito io e le Langhe patrimonio
dell'UNESCO Noi viviamo nel più bel
paese del mondo Abbiamo avuto un culo
pazzesco ragazzi adesso dobbiamo
impegnarci a farci perdonare questa
fortuna sbattendoci Un po' grazie
[Applauso]